now Russians didn't come up with the
idea of public baths the Romans did that
but Russians did take the bathing ritual
to a whole new level today we're here in
st. Petersburg at the old Cossack baths
they were built in 1879 and since then
have seen customers ranging from regular
people like you and me to the infamous
mystic rig Ori respond even Vladimir
Lenin himself
[Music]
[Applause]
the Cossacks were like the special
forces protecting bazaar they live
nearby and they Bay here now the bathing
ritual itself is not for the faint of
heart you start in a scalding hot room
of 200 degrees then you get beaten by
oak and birch branches and then just
when you can't take it anymore you
plunge into ice-cold water
why let's ask the experts there are lazy
be it
Nikolas carotenoids I see I'm silver
condition yes better yet parachute laser
cutter should negotiate in Europe rest
assured of a cheese que deberían
stationer Sergei will promote a to be
Buddhism among the elements trust in
each other and I see there's an exact
science to Russian baths first you
gather the steam from above and gently
guide it to the skin to open up the
pores then the branches hit harder to
get the blood flow going the fragrance
of the pillow made of fresh birch leaves
the rhythm of the branches and the
prickling massage with juniper needles
to stimulate the senses and the
lymphatic flow that was hot but
incredibly pleasant actually and
surprisingly relaxing you know the
aromas of the other branches in the way
he hits you when he gets into the rhythm
it's so it was like hypnotic and now for
the cult much
[Music]
good amazing that's the contact bass for
you I'm certain ard we're National
Geographic
[Music]